foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you guys so much for coming out
tonight uh my name is Hans Kim I'm an
internationally known comedian I just
flew from New York today so
lucky you
uh give it up for a chatto
Shadow no one likes you
he's signing up like everyone should it
takes a lot of Bravery but it also pays
off because you might be able to find
your one and only forever love tonight
that's the goal that's why I wrote the
show
so that I could find love for so that
you could find love uh and speaking of
love I got a really lovely guest tonight
and uh he's really tall handsome he's
got beautiful eyes and he also has
Mississippi one of the funniest
comedians uh in the world and in the tri
Borough area
can we give it up for Kyle Mara
wow Kyle Mara
thank you for coming thanks for that
intro how's it going everybody
good good cool cool this is a horny
audience if I've ever heard of one I
feel it in the air I feel in the air we
got uh one thing on their mind and
that's their next Lover's genitals
[Laughter]
let's get to it we pick out two random
names from the bucket and then we watch
some dates 60 seconds of dating and then
you stay right up here and we interview
you so it should be a fun time
uh quick question quick question is it
is it just straight couples or do you do
like we do gays we got a bucket out for
the gays okay all right cool
I'm looking out for you guys that's why
I asked that's you know I'm just what an
ally
that's how I describe myself an ally
flip this and put it out next time you
get canceled
um first up coming up is the guy that
signed up the latest it's shadow
[Music]
here he comes
luckily the bucket's wet at the bottom
we're gonna pick the wettest name out
we signed up first it's Marty
Martha
get up here Martha going for Martha
wettest name in The Bucket
way to go
I hope you're not Hispanic because
we can make a lot of bad jokes if you
are Hispanic and your name is wet give
it up for Martha and Shadow one minutes
[Music]
starting now nice to meet you nice to
meet you too so are you here with
anybody
um yeah my friend Nathan is in the crowd
just a friend yes just a friend that's
good how about you no I'm not here with
anybody nice nice yeah but that might be
lonely I need friends same yeah all
right sorry Nathan
so uh
I just moved here from Phoenix Arizona
oh okay I actually was in Scottsdale
before I came here oh I was in Mesa but
you know okay yeah
what were you doing in Scottsdale
so it was the end I this past year I've
been traveling all around the country
living in different places and it was
the end of that so just that's cool yeah
do you [ __ ] on the first date no
oh this is going to work do you I do
yeah
yeah
that's what I'm looking for in a
relationship
but yeah no I mean we go second date I
guess
but yeah I'm not kidding
not not so creepy out I think the
tension does not a little weird there
huh so you're traveling all over what
were you doing
um
safer give it up for chatto and Martha
yeah
Shadow not wasting any time getting
right to the Deep questions right to
business yeah I've been here before I
know now yeah you know how to tank a
date
thank you for ruining your day for
comedic effect it did get a lot a lot of
laughs thank you yes that's what you're
counting uh that's cool you asked where
are you who you who are you here with
which isn't one of the recommended
questions yeah I know but straight to
the point again yeah straight to the
point and not getting [ __ ] tonight is
Nathan jealous or is he just a friend
you have to tell him
Nathan are you jealous
okay all right anyway what are you guys
running from in Arizona what uh what was
what brings you here like you know I
came out here to be a comic okay
look brought me here yeah
um just for fun
okay yeah all right seems It's like
Arizona but with slightly more rights
Greener lots more green everything's
Greener just same temperature but green
yeah that's what Texas is known for it's
Greenery yeah it's green I haven't seen
one green thing I've been here for six
hours I'm not gonna lie I think I should
go the greatest thing I've seen is your
shirt yeah man what are you Irish or it
says medicated for your pleasure
he's in his pocket looking for his
condoms just making sure they're not
broken I was looking for the green I
make sure I had the green on me too
straight to the point ah guys
yeah medicated Martha do you do drugs
yes see wow we're building there we go
who knew that people from Arizona do a
lot of drugs
what drugs have you done in Arizona
well I found the perfect guy for you
is medicated for your pleasure
welcome to meet your drug dealer this is
uh this is disguise is the game show but
uh so what did you feel any connection
there or did uh everyone else you know
kind of pick up on The Vibes that were
going on was there like underlying
feelings was it weird that Nathan was
watching you
no that actually was part of it that's
how it usually is because it's always
watching would you be into that shadow
I'm into it have you done that before
I've been there before really yeah
it's like a white man's national sport
it's like basketball to them getting
cucked
foreign
have you been in an open relationship
before that's why I'm here now wow it
turned out horribly
currently currently nice how does that
make you feel Martha
like it's not going to work out that's
why
[Laughter]
I'm not looking for that long-term thing
you know
nope you're not oh so you're just just
have sex just a [ __ ] oh okay gosh I got
you
well you put it out there anyone any
takers didn't think so
[Music]
um
Martha so uh Nathan how did you meet
Nathan I met him on hinge oh what's the
Austin hinge scene like what's like
what's the what's like the the
stereotypical guy like no thanks on
Austin hinge
there is
[Laughter]
um a lot of tech people okay
um a lot of people that like to drink
um a lot of guys say want to [ __ ] on the
first date a lot of guys like that
that's usually the opener actually who
are you here with
I came alone what is this a drug deal
Jesus
what have you noticed about the females
in Austin they're not so willing to put
out on the first date oh
oh do you ask every one of them that's
usually my opener yeah I thought it
worked but I guess it well it's never
worked actually
[Laughter]
yeah that's too bad well don't try that
man keep that one in the uh the chamber
for the next time I will do that uh yeah
that's cool it doesn't seem like you
guys are actually here today
you brought a date and you said what you
said
Martha have you ever been out with a
tech bro before is that your type no I
actually don't date a lot
oh okay yeah
I feel like that's everyone on hinge
says I don't date a lot but then no
longer on hinge oh so this is working
out with Nathan that's what you're
saying no
his friend gotcha he's a hedge friend
hinge friend so I actually met him when
I was traveling before I was just here
for a month
um back in February went on hinged just
said trying to meet friends
trying to find free rent yeah that's the
exact opposite energy of Shadow you're
like I want to find friends he's like
let's [ __ ] right now okay
can we be friends on the first date
basically you're getting it
that's cool so you're traveling around
you're done traveling and you came to
Austin Texas what are you gonna do here
any plans any jobs
um no my job's remote
um so I'm gonna stick with that trying
to buy a house uh what do you do work in
Tech Consulting oh you're in Tech yeah
you're an inside person yep what uh
what's it like dealing with all these
nerds
I'm kind of a nerd myself so yeah yeah
they don't [ __ ] on the first date
I'm feeling something between Hans and
Martha right now I'm not gonna lie are
you guys yeah
that's what you like to get Chad and
Kyle out of here let's yeah let's do it
wow I'm High
um Chad oh yes sir what do you do
I am a struggling business owner
oh yeah now the pandemic put us out we
had a we had quite a few retail stores
and now I moved everything online so I'm
just trying to re
redirect my business now what do you
sell online we sell cannabis education
and CBD products oh there's nothing I
love more than cannabis education yeah
so we get your jobs in the Cannabis
industry I'm kind of like a staffing
agency for uh okay yeah Headhunter but
for like CBD okay interesting
I like how you call it cannabis makes it
so efficient because I'm a professional
you know I'm dedicated for her pleasure
are you pumping Birch right now is this
available on your website they're not
available on my website okay
yeah that would be awesome though well
give it up for a shadow and Mario it
went on a date
[Applause]
thank you for bringing a date to the
dating show
[Music]
the more the merrier
they were both in relationships we got a
straight male named shrew argawal
coming from that table over there and we
got a female coming up
named Brooke
Huns H you know who you are Brooke
hunsker hunsker Hunker I'm trying not to
say the last name of the women oh I'm
sorry oh I'm sorry
here she comes a woman whose last name
we now know
my bad my bad
sorry sorry starting now one minute and
go
how's it going well I haven't had a
drink yet so I'm saying
um what was your name Brooke Brooke I'm
sure nice to meet you nice to meet you
uh are you from Austin
no San Diego oh what brings you to
Austin I've been here for 11 years oh
wow
that's cool
I'm I'm from North Carolina just moved a
couple months ago with some friends
just here
what uh what do you do I'm a I own a dog
grooming business oh that's cool
um I have a golden retriever nice yeah
she's the best very happy dogs
um
thank you for asking all the questions
no problem I appreciate it
um uh I don't really have many more
questions on my mind though
you're doing a good job and time give it
up for Brooke h
and through Argo wall thank you so much
no last names
uh well no one cares about you it's true
you're not gonna get harassed online
relentlessly so your tits aren't big
enough yet
for that to be a worry thank you for
wearing the shirt from your home state
of North Carolina you're very matching
it's like a tar heel blue
that's funny all my friends are uh UNC
alumni but I'm not oh Tar Heels in the
crowd or just in general yeah cool cool
shout out to the Tar Heel Nation
no one cares
Brooke Hunts uh H how's your uh dating
life been
I haven't been on a date in a while
you're living in Austin I would not have
been on this day if my friend had not
put my name in the bucket while I was
grabbing a drink
interesting interesting
so your friend signed you up without
your consent yes well that's kind of
rude
yeah
he'll be the or she'll be whoever your
friend will be the next contestant
because
that's only fair I think
she's better whoa she's calling you a
[ __ ]
well you did great uh so you uh you
moved here 11 years ago
and uh yeah you're
look let me look at my notes
you uh haven't had a drink yet
you're a dog groomer
I want you to groom some of those boots
look at that great boots I love the
boots
a woman with those boots would never
work out the guy in sandals and jeans
though so I'm sorry I just don't think
it's gonna work true you know just I was
not prepared
we're going dancing
it's true maybe you could ask a question
right now
can I come dancing with you sure awesome
oh yeah
wow
did Shadow hear that his first question
wasn't let's [ __ ] it was like hey let's
go for a dance that'd be fun you know
take notes Shadow follow up can my
friends come sure
wow this is a meeting of North Carolina
and Texas it's a good old she's from
California
he's a listener he's a listener
[Applause]
we're picking up on something folks this
is going somewhere I'm telling you this
is
I wouldn't have believed you 30 seconds
ago but now this is electric
can you see yourself grooming dogs for
your future wife
I was actually having this conversation
yesterday that if I win the Powerball
that I would own a golden Farm
is that was that can you explain what
that is for people like me
wants to get peed on on a farm yeah
does that does that turn you on that he
wants to be a dog
breeder a breeder and a groomer wow look
at that not especially okay interesting
she's a rescue gal she's a rescue gal
anyway she's trying sir
uh Brooke said I don't I haven't had a
drink yet and you said same
I think she was looking for you to buy
her drink after this oh no
okay
oh you're not you're not drunk enough
yeah I thought you're like I need a
drink and she was like yeah me too
anyways
um but yeah that's cool you guys are uh
interracial have you ever dated
interracially Brooke yeah
yeah and how black was this guy
dark brown
like shrews brown
yeah about Mexico
so she's used to that the pictures San
Diego she can color correct
this is getting racial uh that's true
big on Adobe thinking Adobe yeah
that's true how's your dating life been
so far uh pretty bad uh last girlfriend
was about a year ago
a year ago oh that's nothing my last
girlfriend was like seven years ago dude
you're crying you're fine you're fine
don't worry about it
yeah you're crushing puss
what happened with your last girlfriend
how did you meet uh we lived in the same
neighborhood and then she moved to
Oregon I moved here
gotcha good old Oregon Trail
um took her away
that's too bad through
how did so you guys were just in the
same neighborhood and you're like hey
I know where you live we have someone we
have dogs that play together so oh
interesting interesting would you have
did your dog have currently have a
groomer
no
I see any client
whoa
I didn't realize we were with the dog
groomer with the Stars over here it's
like it's a waitlist it's a two-year
wait list to get your dog washed by me
what about you have you ever dated
interracially
yeah my last girl was a girlfriend was
late cool cool white girls keep going
anyway uh
there's so many of them here
I can't I really can't I mean in this
country of America
uh Brooke what's kind of favorite what's
your favorite dog to groom
uh poodles
have you ever groomed interracially
that's true what do you do for work I'm
a software engineer who saw that one
coming
[Applause]
if shrew was a dog what type of dog
would he be
this is a good question this wasn't an
odd question that was like a cute
question commented through is already a
dog he's he [ __ ] a woman last year
is is pounding the purse
coded golden retriever oh I told you
that's a good question that's a cute dog
all right
coated red coated
what is he British
anyways uh through
where would you take the lovely Brook on
a day two
I guess dancing
the answer it's a safe bet
is this like line dancing
um no they don't lie and dance in Austin
what type of dancing do you in cowboy
boots in Austin this is a genuine
question I'm curious
well like partner dancing so okay
when I said line dancing that's what I
meant sorry I didn't know I have no I
have no idea what type of dancing that
was just me trying to sound cultured but
okay cool thank you now I know um
have you been dancing before like that
I've never I don't really dance
would you take a dancing class to meet a
girl like Brooke
sure you dance if you don't live again
you don't just twist the light bulb in
that one
uh Brooke so you do the spin your
partner round and round that kind of
dance I
like Honky Tonk that's okay that's where
I was looking for honky doc I wasn't
gonna say it but yes that is called The
Honky Tonk
it's a tonk full of honkies too many of
them if you ask me not in Austin
uh what what's there a lot of racially
over there everyone
's cool it's true are you ready to meet
this
multi-cultural line dancing troupe that
Brooke is a part of I think just one
white woman by the way but uh yeah let's
call it yeah I'm 100 down
nice
well I'm glad that you guys are like
hitting it off and it's gonna happen
please tag us at other people comedy
uh
you know figure it out
what uh what do you think about this
lovely couple Kyle I honestly think
there's there's they're putting up walls
between themselves for no reason I could
see something happening here for real I
really hope you buy her a drink and he
goes at least for one song at a dance
and see where it goes I'm not saying you
need to fall in love but just give love
a chance you too that's what I'm trying
to say I don't believe in love so all
right well then what the [ __ ] are you
doing here okay uh
kidding
look at this smile this guy doesn't
believe in love oh my God he's hoping
Brooke lets him go out with him later
he's begging he's like oh my God she is
gorgeous let's make this happen
what's your favorite romantic movie
through
Hollywood please
that's a good question can I suggest a
fun game can you both say your favorite
rom-com on the count of three
no because if you say the same movie the
same time we'd be like the crowd go
[ __ ] nuts they'd be like oh my God
you've got mail I love You've Got Mail
too oh my God you know meant to happen
I'll give you two seconds to think of it
and then at the count of three
three
two
one The Proposal The Proposal Brooke
didn't say anything
[Music]
Kristen wig Bridesmaids that's not a
rom-com that's a story about a drunk
loser whose friends get married
Noah remembers that part anyway uh
her favorite movie is about someone else
getting married
interesting so main character is
she does I just it's been a while since
I've seen the movie but the proposal you
don't believe in love with your favorite
rom-cons or proposal you're [ __ ]
oozing with I love it where they are
true spare me
I'm telling you this could be something
I see it I see it
Brooke when's the last person that you
dated
the last person that I dated yeah well I
got stood up for a date here on Friday
night
when you say you stood up did they text
you at all or just straight up until
after
um before that I haven't been on a date
for were you excited about the date you
got stood up on
that's a yes everybody that's a big yes
uh sorry to bring the mood down even
lower uh that's this thing where'd you
meet this guy
Apple dates with them three years ago
the old three-year Gap yeah
we're all holding the candles for
someone all right you know what's what
would you go on another date with this
guy
good for you good for you keep it going
for Brooke everyone that's uh that's
I don't know how honest she's being but
you know let's uh that's the right
spirit
okay so what if you had to talk to this
guy that stood up Brooke what would you
say to him and feel free to use any
curse words you want
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you hell
yeah and then what would you do to him
physically
[Applause]
to him yeah
nothing nothing
he's a software engineer he's ever
thrown a punch would you program some
mean code and send it his Direction sure
would you send us info to Anonymous and
just have him like blackballed forever
that'd be fun
are you anonymous to the Russians the
Russians love it oh my God Brooke how
wet are you right now
suru is a man that is ready to defend
you digitally not physically
that's the future Brooke
you can send a lot of Bitcoin your way
um but I hope you guys have a great date
I think that you guys uh you know should
let us know if you guys end up [ __ ]
uh I don't [ __ ] on the first date
uh what a guy oh my God
Martha get his info get his info Martha
this is the opposite of Shadow this
guy's
this guy's out alphaing a Chad you're a
top Chad well thank you so much for
coming on this wonderful date and uh
have a good night please Dance cheers
away come on that dance do that dance
we need a few more males I know males
are easy to come by so
I'll be expecting a little drop in of
male names coming soon Nathan R is a
male who signed up is it Nathan Martha's
Nathan get up here you dog oh my God r
Martha's hinge State going on a date
with Samantha not Martha
get up here Samantha we're sitting right
next to each other
their significant others are gonna make
out while they're on a date on stage
[Music]
please
Nathan with
his date Samantha give it up for
Samantha and Nathan
hey how's it going going really well how
are you doing good what do you do for
work
[Laughter]
um I work in commercials in a set
decorator oh
cool what are you looking for in a
relationship
um I'm wondering how handy you are okay
yeah like around the house like building
things very handy very handy yeah
building shelves you own a chainsaw I do
not own a chainsaw no I don't have a
house I live in an apartment so at some
point I will though I own a chainsaw
okay I can use a chain okay that's
important yeah absolutely that's what
I'm looking for so that's it you could
hire a handyman
[Laughter]
no no that's not it that's okay what
else do you want to get married do you
wanna yes okay cool do you [ __ ] on the
first date
no me neither that was a good question
okay cool what do you do for fun outside
call back
um a rock climb or go hiking where do
you rock climb snowboarding um down at
the green belt or reimer's Ranch oh cool
yeah yeah I used to climb at Crocs like
three days a week and time go to for
Nathan Samantha
yeah dude did you want to finish your uh
rock climbing history
[Laughter]
what kind of rocks do you like to climb
um big ones yeah
do you sometimes climb rocks and then
finish software engineering
no uh for what Like Cocaine
oh no
what are you uh what do you do I work in
finance okay in Austin in Austin is that
a thing not really okay uh he's a bank
teller everybody people go for this bank
teller
foreign
ER I'm not gonna lie I feel like
just go to like 7-Eleven at like 6 a.m
you'll get what you're looking for I
feel like can you paint and use a
chainsaw great come on over here
that's a fun porn
category day laborer porn
yes is it really yeah it should be I
don't know yeah okay who does that who
doesn't want to have sex when you're
hired for a minimum wage manual labor
job
it's like a tip at the end of the day
yeah
all right that went nowhere anyway
um did you uh so yeah are you handy I
thought that was you asking him if he
does hand stuff
[Laughter]
no do you do hand stuff Nathan
what does that mean
finger in a [ __ ]
yeah
nice what's your move what's your go-to
her fingering yeah
put them up there put them up there wow
Martha's like damn
I was like this is why it didn't work
out he's just putting him up there
that's the problem
to put three or four up there and just
figure it out
that's fun that's fun uh do you have you
ever received a handy
yes nice recently
ah no
Samantha uh anyway
um just do it under the table uh just
kidding we're not vulgar like that
um but yeah what uh what's what's your
opinion on uh Nathan what do you think
you think he's good in a pinch
I think you could be good in a pinch
what gives you that idea
wait what what gives you that idea oh I
don't know
I think he's uh bigger than six inch is
um
couplets uh yeah uh uh Samantha so what
is uh what is uh what is your dating
history like
Lee got out of a long relationship
so like but it was not not good so
you're in a good place
[Laughter]
over here she needs a little support
clearly
she escaped it's been a few months and
have you got back in the dating scene
yet no so this is your first date this
is my first date well you can't only go
up from here so don't worry about that
Nathan what's your dating history
um
I'm just like going on dates trying to
find the one you know yeah yeah where do
you meet your women all that uh hinge
hinge yeah
wow I met my date on hinge as well but
oh no you're here on a date three now
well we're friends also so see I know
how that goes nice we met three years a
bunch of friends yeah uh well here on
this show we're more about [ __ ] buddies
so we gotta ditch your friends
team up with each other Maybe
they'll be more uh Lube flying in there
um so you came with your date and then
like the person in front of you came
with or a friend day and that's that's
kind of a coincidence what uh what are
you looking for in a good uh friend date
foreign
comedy shows
nice let someone else do all the talking
we're coming how did you guys meet you
said how did you meet on hinged three
years ago this guy yeah gotcha what was
his opening line anything good
um I'm polyamorous are you down with
that
that's what he said yeah
yeah oh okay I thought you were joking I
was like oh well that's that's an
aggressive first line that's more of a
field first line than a hinge first line
I'm not gonna lie uh sounds like Shadow
was on his chat
wait what does polyamorous mean by the
way [ __ ] lots of people
interesting okay gotcha oh not monog
okay monopod gotcha okay okay anyway
polygons
dating more than one person at a time
monogamous relationship interesting does
that ever work out
uh
I don't we didn't do that we
we just became friends oh so he was like
uh I'm Polly and you're like nah I'm
good
they're mono
mono Emery
Nathan these polygon jokes doing
anything for you no
what's your ELO in chess
uh
a thousand
Loser yeah
uh that's cool so what uh what do you
like to do for fun besides you know
going on dates and on hinge uh I like to
run a lot I read you know go to bars go
to Comedy stuff read go to bars run are
you like uh American Psycho uh a little
bit nice Christian Bale
what do you think about the new Huey
Lewis album no idea
I heard about his best stuff since his
first album yeah I couldn't think of a
line sorry uh are you uh so you're like
uh intense kind of guy you like uh
fighting crime Maybe
yeah okay yeah I think if you could be
one superhero what would it be
Iron Man interesting oh you do come feel
like you're the money guy okay how about
you if would you [ __ ] Iron Man
definitely interesting in the suit
find uniform sexy wow okay but how would
you so just be that the mask and the top
half then it would just be
it'd be like Winnie the Pooh meets Iron
Man you know just dick out
and then just suit it up could you do
that do you have a confidence for that
Nathan yeah
yeah it's got the iron dick
what uh what superhero would you be
Samantha
there's like two women would you be
Wonder Woman or Xena the Warrior
Princess certainly not a lot of options
for women I don't I was kind of thinking
more of the the cat lady Catwoman
she's not a cat lady that's what
there's some like nerd out there being
like those are two different universes
this one's MCU one is DC that'll never
[ __ ] work all right
do you have a cat
do I have a cat no I don't yeah that's
good yeah
I want to be the only [ __ ] in the house
we're seeing a different side to
Samantha and I like where it's going all
right
someone get her a drink
Shadow anyway uh
so what's your fascination with
chainsaws
I have a lot of trees I need to get cut
down
does your date know about that right now
he does not gotcha he's like a barley
looking dude I think he was gonna sleep
over and tomorrow just be cutting down
trees
hey are you freedom
so she's not of environmentalist
um they're all dead okay oh quilt yeah
you're just maintaining nature
um so yeah Nathan are you
um are you looking forward to like maybe
going on a second date maybe you can
take her dancing with uh shrew over
there we'll do a double date you know
and the Broken Spoke tear it off bring
over Martha and whoever Samantha's date
is
you think that they'll hit it off you
got to know Martha
yeah I think they could hit it off nice
good but I think he might be more into
Brooke
well yeah I mean screw is already taken
unless you want to fight him you know on
cyberspace I would suggest
I feel like a Nathan true fight would be
the worst fight in this world I don't
know
they'd be like and that would be it
would just be a quick just be like an
episode of Big Bang Theory
The Gangs get in a fight and practice
Samantha in the corner just like let's
get the [ __ ] out of here anyways
this was never gonna work
well thank you guys for coming up on a
date I hope that it goes well and if it
does please tag us
yeah take photos thank you we're into
that type of thing or videos yep
we got a couple more dudes left and a
couple more ladies we're gonna have to
stretch them out we got Igor M Igor get
up your Igor
we got Igor coming up oh here he is is
he friends with shrew support
we got Kara sabolt no last names Hans
Cara you might as well come up now oh is
that Brook's friend
hell yeah keep it going for uh care
everybody Kara seabolt
I forgot I was gonna bring her up
Igor M Igor's not coming up
we're gonna get
it what the hell yeah Elon put us
Avon
oh here he is he knew exactly what he
was
handwriting is not so good on this one
watch out
yeah I figured you're gonna mess up my
name what is your name Avon Alon Alon
pedute Israeli oh okay hold on I don't
know how I [ __ ] that up
this [ __ ] is right under my nose Okay
one minute starting now
how's it going
hey how are you so like Elon like Elon
Musk no uh it's kind of I think it's
kind of similar I'm not sure
no it's a-l-o-n oh yeah it means Oak in
Hebrew and then the third tree I don't
know anything about any of her stuff
um are you Christian
I mean ish kind of I was brought up that
way I guess and then decided to just
I mean do you think Jesus is like the
Son of God no no so okay I just think
that's all silly but whatever
so what do you believe
uh I guess in the Golden Rule what is
that well you just treat people the how
you would want to be treated I love it
that's awesome I think that's kind of
the foundation of all the religions
right
I don't know
I don't know Christian's like you don't
believe in Jesus You're Going to Hell
Muslims like you don't believe in Islam
you're gonna kill you and time
give it up for Alon
foreign
Karen Karen or Cara it's Kara
like Sarah wow that was black belt level
dating I've never
talked about religion with a Jew on the
first date
first question will you convert uh
no that's not easy way we don't accept
easily you know it's not like
Christianity except Jesus okay you're in
Jews you know you have to work for it
Jesus Christ very hard
I'm not religious at all but you better
be [ __ ] Jewish okay that's
foreign
's coming out guns blazing because of
Kanye this week yeah yeah I know what
did he say I don't follow the news he
said something about Jews what the [ __ ]
happened nothing he said nothing it's
fine
I mean he's crazy as [ __ ] right who
keeps the [ __ ] what he says I don't I
feel like you guys will get along
because you kind of came out pretty hot
too so I think it's
kind of cute
he looks like Jon Stewart's evil twin
he looks like he writes for Jon Stewart
so how long have you been in Austin are
you visiting from Israel no I've been
here 10 years 10 years okay yeah what's
the Jewish dating scene like in Austin
oh it's terrible right I went to a uh
Passover de J
ude I get why we get all the like the
noses this it's not good oh my God I
don't get it man I mean Israeli women
don't have that weird Jewish notes but
here holy [ __ ]
all right we think we know why elon's
been single for so long by the way after
that one uh dude how do you even kiss
someone like that like it's impossible
it's like you know yeah you make it work
I don't know for New York I think
there's a couple Jewish girls it's not
that big of a deal come on I'm glad we
have our resident Jewish correspondent
to say the most racist things against
Jewish people hey I get to right this is
the first Jewish anti-seminine ever met
my entire life dude you know I did uh I
did a 23andMe and I was really hoping to
see that I'm not Jewish I was like that
explains a lot but 98 Ashkenazi Jews
like wow man who was surprised by that
one uh no one here
[Music]
I think I would get a free pass in the
Holocaust you have blue eyes yeah you
could be a Nazi right like me you wish I
had a line dude other line
would you would you betray your people
like that
he's like he's the one picking I was
like that knows definitely a Jew get
over here he's uh
nice I have a question yes do you know
who Julian Assange is
I do yeah I do know yeah why
he's in jail and he's in the UK and he's
a truth teller and I just want to know
like I would never date anybody who was
not a truth teller
hey
um
I'm just saying like do you care about
politics and what the real truth is and
not the propaganda that the media tries
to tell us yes I do but I think messing
with it too much is best for your mental
health so I try to stay away from it I
agree I mean did you hear what happened
in Israel now baby came back
yeah just like Trump getting reelected
so better stay away from it it sucks
yeah well uh nothing worse than talking
about politics with the Jews talk about
religion I mean religion rules nothing
gets my dick hard like the Israel
Palestine conflict right guys
I know the way man oh
thank God yeah I was gonna try to avoid
that as much as possible yeah my bad I
don't even know
I apologize wondering like
so what do you think about Christians
Elon about what what do you think about
Christians they're all about this Jesus
Guy what's the big deal
I mean
first of all I was married to a
Christian
that's the reason I'm here
uh we have a daughter and my daughter is
very Christian so I guess I need to be
for it you know what type of
Christianity uh Southern Baptist Jesus
Christ oh man oh no yeah
but hey I mean I asked you like you
don't mind that I'm going to hell and
she says no you're Jewish you get a free
pass so I was like okay okay what a good
dog so now you can go dancing with me
and Brooke yeah [ __ ] yeah I love to
dance but you're all going two steps
right two stepping yeah okay
I'm down
wow all right uh
take photos this is clearly going
somewhere
um how about you what was the last that
you've been on
uh last night
really wow you really are good at dating
to Swift static and we had a really good
dinner and
we'll watch some TV
all right
for those of you at home that means she
[ __ ] less than 24 hours ago
why do you think Brooke says you're good
at dating what do you think that means
yeah I mean I just go on I've been
single longer and I'm more assertive
maybe we could tell we got that Vibe for
sure yeah
yeah you were like what's your name mean
are you like Elon is that a good thing
to be like Elon or would you have been
like nope that you sound like a Julian
Assange hater which is a deal breaker
for me
why did you ask if his name was Elon or
Elon no I just thought he was saying his
name was Elon like Elon Musk is a big
deal these days on Twitter everybody's
losing their [ __ ] mind where does
Elon sit in terms of Julian Assange how
many Julian assangeas Does Elon have
actually I'm disappointed that he hasn't
spoken out for Julian Assange Warren he
should
what is with you and Julian Assange
free speech
yeah
that journalists should be in jail for
telling the truth and telling the truth
about U.S war crimes
do you have like a website about this or
I mean not personally no but um defend
Julian Assange is a good website okay
he's in jail for three years already
for doing nothing but telling the truth
you remember like the whole collateral
murder thing like that right show that
they put out yeah I mean that's kind of
what we do it's America we wrongfully
imprisoned someone well we do a lot of
national Pastime yeah Elon what do you
think about uh
where do you what do you think about you
don't think about politics that much
what do you want to do with uh
Cara tonight maybe more in the present
in the moment something fun like besides
sounds like we're going dancing after so
we might I mean you're welcome we're
just gonna go to the Continental Club
you guys are all welcome we should all
go
or you could stay here and buy some more
alcohol
tickets for the next show are only ten
dollars this whole room was gonna be
talking about two minutes ago and then
that whole Jillian Assange thing
happened and we all got very dry
it shouldn't be trying
what uh what do you think about you know
the Iraq War Elon Iraq war is it War
there now
well it happened
Oh you mean the past one yeah I don't
know it was awesome give us your
thoughts on operation Operation Freedom
Pro or con sorry Operation Freedom are
you a fan what's Operation Freedom come
on Christ Iraqi freedom
that's the name that we gave the Lord
better you guys
the first one I was in Tel Aviv and
missiles were falling like on on Israel
so that was interesting well you got to
forgive us Americans we don't really
know where Iraq is we're like that looks
good I think that's interesting you
actually understand
where is like you
like he's where missiles have fallen and
most of us have not and so this is
important to like realize we're just
kind of like numb here you know like we
don't yeah we need more missiles falling
no we don't that's the whole point
well the first time it was scary but
then it just became okay I guess
nothing's happening so we stopped giving
a [ __ ] yeah yeah it's like a tornado
warning the Iraqis had like shitty
missiles so
yeah I missed the beginning of this date
when Anna had a bunch of hot takes and
Samantha wanted to [ __ ] that was more
fun right that was a way better vibe
I feel like I'm on like Meet the Press
right now with just a bunch of idiots
it's just no it's good I feel like Elon
would take you on a date to pick up his
kids
[Laughter]
you got a real divorce that energy and
I'm loving it
do you know how to work your way around
the grill I do
but no pork right no I ate pork Oh you
are a bad Jew I actually I am a terrible
Jew but actually now I'm hunting I'm
eating only meat that I hunt oh [ __ ]
yeah we have the same daddy you and me
Joe Rogan uh he's your Daddy yeah I
thought this was gonna be you're like
Step Brothers you and me nice when we're
both here at the creek in the cave on a
Sunday at six so uh but yeah love Joe
Rogan love hunting my own meat I thought
no I love that concept of it I love that
idea
what I thought this was going to be a
Jeffrey Dahmer confession I loved it
when did you kill your last
um
um when was it
four months ago why tell whitetail deer
yeah that seems like a lot I'm going
again in a month
Cara do you hunt Cara
I what do you hunt no
no are you turned off by hunting I mean
a product
okay I wasn't sure where was that going
with the whole free speech thing earlier
and then I don't know how Austin you are
but you do eat meat right yes nice okay
good because if you're a vegan that
would be a deal breaker yeah no no I
used to be vegan but now for the same
reasons I hunt you did yeah I gave it a
good try now you're an avid Hunter so
what happened there it's for the same
reasons seriously like at the best
ethical meat possible food yeah
wow very uh modern Jewish man right he's
doing all the things he shouldn't
uh but yeah that's cool Cara what are
you ethnically are you Jewish maybe a
little bit no just say yes I'm just like
a Polish generically white I don't know
gotcha
where's your family from you like maybe
England Germany I don't know okay the
famous that might be bad right they're
right next to each other
okay German English he's into it he
likes everything Jews don't like so if
you're a German that's even better
that's like the pork of people for Jews
it's okay they started the Holocaust
but uh yeah anything that you'd like to
say to Elon before you guys take off for
the Continental Club
no I thought it was fun meeting you yeah
and you were funny thank you thank you
Cara giving Ayla the compliments I wish
you would give us
uh Elon anything you want to say to Kara
you guys were fine
um you should have said that to Elon I
like your essence of pursuing Justice
thank you yeah it's a weird you I feel
you kind of picked a weird cause yeah
but hey I mean it's great and uh yeah I
mean I think I'm gonna stay for the
comedy after a little bit but yeah yeah
container Club there's dancing tonight
yes okay well we'll see you there watch
them two step their way over there thank
you
uh mazel tov
shalom shalom Elon and Camera everyone
let him hear it
good job you guys
I'm so proud of you
I feel like those two would have sex and
I'd read a book you know I would be one
of those vibes they just
they're gonna go pet cats together
we got uh our producer coming up the
wonderful beautiful Sam Kuiper is gonna
go on a date with a female and her name
is Olga the female pick it up here
there she comes and feel free to sign up
we need at least one more couple
so go ahead and sign on up
Olga and Sam starting now hi
how are you I'm Sam okay I'd love to
meet you nice to meet you as well Olga
are you um
where are you from I'm from Ukraine okay
so I'm a little nervous when was the
last time you cried
uh you know uh probably
I don't know
I don't know how bad I don't know I
don't know my masculinity is kicking in
it's just like I don't know what to say
right now I don't [ __ ] cry dude never
never maybe at the gym yeah when I look
at my lack of gains in the mirror that
[ __ ] tear comes down that's true so
you cried today
what is so is it depression or is it
just a like you're really in tune
feels really good man start crying right
now are you are you on drugs or no
actually like
mushrooms you haven't done mushrooms
two what was your did you enjoy it or
I love mushrooms yeah yeah all the time
I mean yeah I would do it right now
probably
do you want to do mushrooms together
absolutely
and time
for Olga Sam
we're doing drugs guys
they just uh agreed to do schedule one
narcotics tomorrow
[Laughter]
yeah with a side of crying because I
know what you do on the first date
the only thing missing is the location
up to you FBI salutes yeah
thank you for uh your service being
Ukrainian I hope those Javelin missiles
served you well oh
what uh made you cry recently
it knows mainly for the jokes okay okay
I thought you're gonna say the village
of Curson
keeping up
all right
I've been keeping up with the things you
guys make great content over there now I
think
the first time I cried was when I
when I I trauma bonded with another
comedian over having dead dads and I had
to text him saying I can't go because my
grandmother had died that day damn you
one-upped him oh yeah yeah you're like
you got a dead dad my whole family's
dead you ever heard of cursage was your
grandma actually dead yeah oh okay they
just faked a death I was like that's
pretty ruthless uh are you a comedian
no are you trying to be one
okay you're more concerned about saying
no to go to a comedy show than your dead
grandma
you're like Elon hating the Jews you
just hate your own family that's [ __ ]
up come on
God damn it Grandma [ __ ] Joe Rogan's
on a Tuesday
well I hope you uh didn't cry too long
um because that's the opposite of Comedy
thank you Sam uh What uh what do you
think about Olga she's a very wonderful
person yeah uh I just how long have you
been here or did you like were you there
when it was going down or no you were
there last week I was sensitive I have
to be with this topic
okay but it didn't start like about
seven months ago
at the [ __ ] out of there you were one of
the first you know welcome to Refugee
dating everybody
you came to Austin started doing
mushrooms started crying a lot it's been
a transformational experience
did you come by yourself or did you no
my lovely friend who's right here she
forced me to put the name in the hello
lovely friend
yeah oh [ __ ] oh wow
that's good I like to see that you guys
keep up your friendship
nice to see it only for some what do you
guys talk about you too sorry it's not
that good but what about that you're
like where'd you get that dude oh my God
those don't come out till next month
so seriously what are your troop
movements this month
it's cool
Sam what uh what kind of white are you
um as wide as it gets I'm from Alabama
so
okay but like before that
oh
[Laughter]
my God what do you mean well before that
like I was
I went on a date with my dad and I left
with my mom and then I came out nine
months later you know people
and I was in Alabama when it happened so
you know for people from Alabama aren't
always white like they usually moved to
Alabama from somewhere else no I was
born in Alabama I moved out of Alabama
when I was 10 and um oh my God white
people you guys are driving me crazy
yeah we're not very interested
just do a 23andMe or like ask your
parents figure out what you are and then
find out what kind of uh food you're you
should be eating okay like if you're
from Iceland you could be eating fish
right now no I did do my ancestry before
23andMe came out I'm just like Eastern
European so like hey it might be one of
your friends or enemies
cousin yeah hey I'm from Alabama that
doesn't make it weird for me
there you go
I see a similar nose over here similar
profile
yeah maybe you could draft him into
service send them to you know your
president
here's a question would you Funk would
you [ __ ] zelinski
really I thought
zielinski if I'm being honest
that dude's just got all of the
confidence
I can't tell if we like him or not the
media is too hot and cold or too hot on
them so I don't know if he's just like
crushing or just [ __ ] up all the time
so I don't know but anyway you think
he's hot
uh yeah sure I mean he's also an
ex-comedian started Ukrainian version of
SNL so I thought you guys would be
massive fans of him I haven't seen his
stuff are you are you a chuckle [ __ ]
you travel bonded with the comedian and
he loves zelinski because he was a
former comic what's going on with you
I think you're in man I think this is
yeah just quick comedy and become the
president yeah
like the chess club or I don't think I
can another name
I was in I was in Atlanta recently and I
was like talking to the Uber driver I
was like where are you from like and
he's like I'm just regular white and I
was like all right calm down it was just
like very aggressive I was trying I
asked him like I was like oh not
nationality he's like just regular I was
like okay uh good to know yeah
she wants to be a comedian it's so clear
yeah you have to be the next Ukrainian
president what is your tattoo is that uh
Shrek
I went to the Shrek Rave yesterday okay
it's really Shrek right here I'm not
being like an [ __ ]
it's dope where did you get it from
he dressed as Lord Farquaad okay
it's going around with a wet sponge
putting temporary tattoos on Facebook do
you guys know what the Shrek Rave is by
the way by a round of applause
no half and half I have no it's the
craziest [ __ ] I see on the internet in
the past six months it's absolutely nuts
it was equal parts fabulous and absolute
trash it's like an EDM concert just with
like the remix soundtrack from the Shrek
movies and just
people like her going [ __ ] crazy for
three hours that's all it is a lot of
what type of drugs you take what type of
drugs did you take
interesting she just she knows the FBI
is listening that's why she's backing up
on these questions
do you smoke weed or no
no okay not just so just mushrooms yeah
no weed treats me poorly I get paranoid
I get yeah I start feeling like I'm
flying off I feel like the Russians are
bombing your country on weed
she remembers you cocaine
no how crazy do you just just mushrooms
only not since 2019
. what happened in 2019 yeah 2019. she's
like that's when the Russian started
putting fentanyl on your cocaine so uh
come back to Russians yes about the
Russians
so if Putin didn't do all the [ __ ] he
did would you [ __ ] Putin too
no
like if Putin was a comedian and he
didn't [ __ ] run Russia
he's not particularly attractive but
he's Rich he's very very
I'd [ __ ] be as many horses yeah I
wouldn't do this
we'll just film it and
does Lindsay have money
I mean now he does he's a president of a
country I don't think it's his money but
he gets to spend it do you guys mind if
I can watch
I want to watch
what would it be called
two idiots [ __ ] two idiots
foreign
this is where my comedy let's get back
to the issue at hand anyway uh which one
you're on a date
where are you taking on your first date
we go to
um get some food see if we Bond or Vibe
and then like maybe go to listen to some
music Continental club's dope I'm not
the best dancer but I'll try to make a
fool of myself for you if it if that's
what you want so
laughs making a fool of himself just
like the ukrainians in the village of
Cassandra
yeah just kidding
I'm from the politics and he's brought
us right back what's your favorite race
to date
I have to have a favorite one that's not
what yeah who's someone that you dated
that wasn't White
Asian wow
[Laughter]
how dare you to steal our white women
uh that's cool Asian
um that's cool was there anything
different about dating an Asian guy
you hear that
it's the same size
laughs
I mean he was Canadian though so I don't
know oh
gross I was into it but now I'm not what
Why didn't it work out
uh well I mean we're still kind of in
the middle of a little bit of a
situationship but you know interesting
they're still [ __ ] but they're
looking for your poly
okay
I didn't even if Polly was like out to
Austin really and like everyone's
probably and I don't have the balls to
say that I'm Polly but like I kind of
wanna
[Laughter]
it's more of a bank account issue for me
I hear people say it and like girls are
like I was on this date with this guy
and he was like I'm Polly and I was like
[ __ ] jealous dude
you can do it here it's not illegal like
in Alabama
I feel like you have to be either super
rich or just super poor to be Polly it's
got to be one of the two it's like like
homeless poor yeah
have you ever dated a homeless person
lives in a
Buck well like is it his bus or is it
like he sneaks in after school
I don't like that second one that was
the first yeah some questions yeah all
right so she [ __ ] a guy on a bus once
anyway
city bus or uh yeah was it on Metro
cinder blocks like what was going on
here was it like a house
okay interesting to do nowadays ever
since the Russians bombed their country
everyone's living in a bus they're
resourceful people the Ukrainian people
like oh wow this is a good use of metal
we don't have a lot in my country right
now
Sam uh what have you dated interracially
before Sam yeah updated uh the hall
races really yeah I've even [ __ ] a
girl in South Korea
what anyway I don't know where I was
going with that
it was she was South Korean oh that's a
that's a little too much information
we get it you can you you're I was in
the military for a little while that's
why I was over there oh no it's okay
yeah yeah anyway we love we love that
uh do you like a man in uniform
I do have a tendency to date military
men I've been trying to break that yeah
I've been uh out since 2016 so
yeah
of the military or the closet
um the military are you in still in the
closet I guess if that's huh what branch
were you in I was in the Navy I was in
aviation uh okay I got it so definitely
still in the closet yeah yeah we just
said we'd [ __ ] zielinski and poop
two idiots [ __ ] two idiot who's
kidding who yeah thank you for doing
your part to serve this wonderful
International Community uh Olga or the
army
military he's in the Navy so I don't how
does that make you feel any any uh
knowledge about Navy men have you ever
been with a navy man before just keep
hearing their hoes but that's about it
that's true she's from a landlocked
country she knows nothing about the Navy
we're just like they barely have an army
over there so
yeah sorry about uh Crimea thanks
well the thing on Navy men they're all
great and stuff but you gotta check
their underbelly for Barnacles if you
know what I mean they got a lot of STDs
it's Barnacles the new slang for STDs
anyways uh Sam what is your religion I
was born Catholic but I don't I'm
agnostic I think oh I believe something
but what is your religion please don't
say much not much what would your
parents hope you'd be
never really had that conference dad was
a rocket scientist he was a religious
complete oh okay I got you all right
Ukrainian rocket scientist I wonder what
he's up to right now I'm glad she's dead
whoa they got him folks they got him
they got him Sam quick do you have any
dead family members my grandma died of
natural causes uh both of them what a
privileged white ass you are yeah
my grandma's last name was glowwalki I
think she was polish or something I
don't know I'm like I'm confused where
I'm from
ancestry made it more confusing I'm from
Alabama like who settles in Alabama
brother sisters sister wife I'm only
child
yeah so um
thank God just had to want to be done
with it from Alabama yeah God damn it
that went nowhere
wow Sam you're from Alabama you said it
twice now he did you got that Alabama
chromosome I do do you have a brother uh
siblings no not at all not anymore are
you dead or
Jesus Sam
how do you how do you know if you don't
ask you know what I mean what am I
do [ __ ] on the first date
no are you polyamorous
yeah
she's in a situationship she's currently
Paulie so what so yeah you're the only
child as well yeah wow you guys are two
bunch of [ __ ] losers the closest
thing to homeschooled kid is uh only
child oh yeah yeah what about your
Source it's not your Source what did you
guys do on your free time
read a lot read a lot that's not
something Sam did no I don't yeah you
could teach him to read I can read I
just choose not to
I don't I just honestly I have like ADHD
I have no attention span for I'll read a
page and I'll reread the page and then
I'll be like what the [ __ ] did I just
read
and then I'll read it again and I'll be
like I'm done with this [ __ ] it's like
green eggs and ham yeah three times I
read that page dude it doesn't make
sense
well give it up for Sam the literate and
Olga the Warrior Princess a Polly
Warrior Princess let her hear it
some more names we got one more couple
left they just signed up we got Bob and
Jay you're going on a date together Bob
and Jay come on up
you just signed up I saw you
get on up here Bob and Jake
okay they're not oh here's Bob
and here's Jay
they're a Duo
taking the creative way on stage hey
how's it going look at it what's going
on fellas what a unique experience this
is gonna be wait we decided to go on a
date together we signed up to have a
polyamorous relationship with some
unlucky victim well let's see if you
deserve it
all right that was aggressive
go on a date uh or just like speak your
mind and do a little infomercial for
yourselves for one minute starting now
go ahead uh buy now for 9.99
for myself I thought we were gonna go I
thought you were going to introduce us
to a date yeah unfortunately Olga
already went up she was the other name I
thought there was another name in there
that said any ladies in the crowd want
to
try this out
come on up Casey get up here Casey Come
on Casey
Casey Casey Casey
oh she's coming coerced by our friend
don't worry Casey you can bring your
friend up next
oh we're doing a double oh there's
Brooke
oh wait I thought I thought uh Cara was
Brooke's friend double the men too okay
not please you give it up for Casey go
on a date with Bob
Bob and Jay
[Applause]
how are you
doing good thanks
do you actually want to come here with
your friend just bully you into this
I wanted to come to the show and watch I
didn't really want to be up here I know
I'm sorry I got bullied into it
I'm the one that likes to watch the date
like what we're trying to do is uh we've
been hearing about this poly thing and
uh I personally I'm against it I think
it's disgusting and you're going to hell
uh
well because you're greedy you're greedy
and you're disgusting and you just want
everything handed to you and you don't
want to do the work that it takes to I
think a real relationship would have
right
we're not talking about what that was I
asked them like what Paulie what's Polly
it means you have like you you
theoretically it means you can love
multiple people
right and and I think in actuality it
means you have an STD probably yeah
okay
I'm very Pro polyamory if you're here
now I just want you to know I wish you
nothing but happiness I don't see it in
your future but I wish it for you
sincerely and time give it up for Bob
and Jay and Casey was also here
yeah it's a minute of dating
yeah I'm so sorry
yes welcome to the show that's been
going on for an hour and a half I mean
you're right we should have watched we
should have so what are you guys a
comedy troupe from Canada
sure yeah
do I look Canadian because that's
amazing I would love to be able to leave
you guys have the beautiful comedy
yeah I know right my crazy white
privilege you guys are like Roadies for
a cover band that's what I feel like we
totally are you guys uh best friends you
guys already know each other uh we met
outside and we were like there's this
audience member
their names are Bob and Jay oh you know
what I didn't even put that together
until just now yeah we are Bob and Jay
for real Bob and Jay
all right I'm Bob he's Jay
I am a good wingman so I think uh my
friend here my single friend Bob here uh
is a wonderful sweetheart of a person
he's had his heart broken by uh some
psychotics before
lots of drugs that's what he means
I'm not and probably not my type oh no
no trust me he'll he'll make a breakfast
uh even if you beat him I don't know how
to cook yeah totally beat me Casey what
do you think about this unique
experience that you could only use other
people comedy questions
those are pretty cool shoes hey thanks
man are those cowboy boots no they're uh
they're like half boots I like Chelsea
boots guys would you ever [ __ ] a guy in
cowboy boots Casey
yeah okay all right cool that's we're
getting somewhere uh you asked for a
question that's all I could think of
have you [ __ ] a guy on cowboy boots
before I mean
I mean while we were [ __ ] the boots
would come off of course yeah yeah yeah
well that's a deal breaker for me I have
to wear the boots so
well the metal things
um the metal things I've been here for
six hours
um but uh where are you from I'm from
New York you're talking about our San
Antonio basketball team the Spurs got it
got a chicken I know it just took me a
second
um that moment's passed anyway uh how
about cowboy boots that's that's hot uh
Casey how long have you been in Texas
I've been in Texas for two and a half
years what brought you down here I'm
from Indiana so I don't like the cold
and just more opportunity here yeah we
get it when you said Indiana we're like
that makes sense
dental hygienists meaning your teeth are
no I just mean I can get a job anywhere
basically because we have teeth here
on dates do you wash their teeth do you
look at their teeth to kind of Judge
them a little bit a little bit okay
I mean we can tell y'all are enjoying
this right Jay I hate you yeah this was
a bad idea
that you don't like that's still kind of
told what's the weird thing about teeth
what's the one has there been like a
snaggletooth where the guy's got a big
dick maybe like I can't we understand
your question
here's a better question have you ever
worked for a dentist that killed
themselves no oh that's a bummer I
thought that was gonna be a yes that's a
thing though right have you heard
dentist have you have you worked for a
dentist that like their dentist friend
from dentist school like kill themselves
no have you ever had a dentist you wish
kill himself
[Laughter]
I thought you said you're bad at dating
why are you trying to give us advice I
like how you thought that was the worst
question than your question so anyway uh
Jay what's your dating history like have
you been [ __ ] well no uh I'm a I'm a
I'm a very dirty prude in that uh I'll
wait I wait I take my time and if uh if
you're worth it then I'll surely have
sex with you but if I think at some
point it's just going to be a waste of
time or if you you like some stupid [ __ ]
that I think is awful and shallow then
I'm probably not gonna [ __ ] you and
you're do you uh do you uh
based on who I am and what I look like
so Jay
having the goal to even invent a
scenario I like it the more words you
say the more chance you have a success
uh Jay do you have like a great sword in
your room hung prominently no I feel
like this revealed something I just feel
like you're like you have a sword in
your room because you respect like the
Medieval ages and respect and chivalry
and you you might have a
[ __ ] out of you and oh [ __ ] do you lick
[ __ ] do you lick butts I feel like
this is getting weird
you put in front of me I'm married
you look like the bad guy from uh Never
Ending Story
or the princess The Princess Bride I
mean
all right let's give Bob a chance here
Bob okay
let's give Bob a chance yeah my chance
is to give Bob a chance Bob you're going
you see Casey she goes on a date with
you where are you taking her
do you like sushi
okay the not sushi
um what what do you like what kind of
food are you into I like
all right so Mexican food Mexican food
cold and chewies probably someplace like
middle of the road so I can step it up
afterwards and there you go strategy I
like oh there you go let's go you don't
want it wrong her favorite food is
margarita
[Laughter]
oh you're my type so that's fine
sushi I'm guessing
or in your past history what's the one
that stands out you're like I can't
believe this [ __ ] took me there
Wendy's
she wants questions from us guys let's
be honest yeah go ahead
keep it going what was the last day you
went on Casey
when was the last date
are you on one now did your date push up
here okay
it was probably a month ago and was he
was he cool was he lame are you gonna
see him again are you seeing him now are
you Polly what's going on did you [ __ ]
on the first date no we didn't we did
not
smooch did he asked we did the whole
he did stay the night but we didn't have
sex
then
was he homeless I'm not gonna get too
much information here but I don't know
why I didn't like him I just didn't I
just kind of yeah ghosted him it's
probably from Ukraine or something
um well I
I don't know I was on Tinder and then I
came across his name and it said
something like Kink friendly on his
Tinder and then that just kind of
creeped me out and you're like I gotta
swipe right off do you want to date with
him after I went on a date with him
interesting so where'd you meet him
originally
[Music]
oh my God holy
oh where do you work I thought he was
cute so I put my number in his goodie
bag and then yeah he's gonna be due in
like three months and then I'm gonna
have to clean his teeth again oh this is
where we should have started the show oh
my Lord
I feel like I'm watching a porn right
now this guy I can't believe Brooke said
you weren't the one that was good at
dating
you're an excellent dater yeah
well that's that's cool uh I can't
believe I can't believe you put a number
in a guy's gift bag but that wait wait
hold on but then but then King shamed
him three months later you're like what
a freak who would do something like that
is this cake
no no but he did philosopher me after
that he sent me selfies have been
flossing and I was like so cute oh my
God maybe that was his Kink maybe that
was his Kink he just likes ropes
what's that called the it's like with an
H word with one when they like the ropes
thank you Marta anyway uh
[Music]
it was just the fact that it was on his
Tinder like basic information I was just
like okay that's a red flag
[Music]
I didn't know it was just a [ __ ] app
which someone else told me that too yeah
stolen from the
gay eating in love
so you met this guy at your office then
you saw him on Tinder later
yeah wow and then
you picture and sent it to me like hey
because I stopped talking to him and
then I was like
is this uh the opportunity that you
moved from Indiana for it's just a hit
on our
literally moved here with the guy
oh I'm so sorry
what happened to him is he here now with
your friends no no
now
yeah
he's in the past so now I'm dating and
that's why I'm like oh I just get
creeped out
here but I'm having fun well luckily you
went on a date with Bob and Jay
the most well we're actually super
Charming in real life the problem is
there's four of us in this relationship
right now and we're trying to
accommodate there's five of us okay
four guys right so and you guys are
doing well I'm not judging you there's a
hole for every one of us we can just do
a human centipede I just wish you hadn't
said that good Lord man she just said
she's terrified of the word Kink and you
just I didn't get that Vibe I think
she's indicating just not being like out
there
make your own holes all right but Bob so
what's uh
when's the last time you on a date
last time I was on a date yeah uh three
months ago and uh where'd you meet her
uh at a coffee shop coffee shop okay how
do you approach that you go up turn to
say hello no she went over there yeah
she was working there and uh um I would
go in and they make great coffee and I
was just like this coffee is great she
was like yeah thanks that's what I do
and I was like yeah but not everyone
does it that well and it started in that
weird like back and forth It's called
chemistry yeah I guess I thought it was
chemistry but then we went out and I was
like oh maybe you just don't like me and
I tricked you into going on this date
with me
this is incredible and then you go on
again it's just it's just awkward the
whole night and you're like maybe I'm
bad at this I get that yeah that happens
yeah I shouldn't have put my number in
his goodie bag did she write it in like
the phone it was really impressive
sincerely I was like holy [ __ ]
that would be funny I actually remember
why I didn't like him I couldn't
remember everything
because when we talk talked on the phone
for the first time he was playing video
games
and he really wasn't even listening to
me I could tell he had like no response
and then when we went on like date one
two I would be telling stories and
you'd be playing video games respond
after I'd be like
funny the way I said it was fun
ction from it so interesting what would
you say your love language is talking on
the phone
thing what is your love language I don't
use this word I just know it's a dating
term uh I think I like quality time
quality time well if you're looking for
a listener we got through over here yeah
we're all pulling for shrew he can
listen yeah thank you what the hell man
you can listen to up to seven women at
the same time
and not want to kill himself what a guy
it's a
so uh what's your love language Bob mine
is gifts I can't help it I like it
compliments I'm a big complimenter oh he
likes to spoil the ladies yeah
because you're under selling I thought
it was like one of the best people I've
ever met when you
I'm too nice
I dressed down on intentionally so
people don't realize
bye now right time off her I'm not
comfortable with sleeping on the first
date either
um so that's not gonna happen but it was
cool to hang out with you tonight like
I'm enjoying this this is nice wow he's
playing hard to guess you just brought
the worst wingman ever Bob that's your
problem see what I mean like Jay is
going out of his way to try and help me
and I keep being like it's not gonna
work out don't worry what he's saying
around so like we're never going to see
each other again
we'll be married in six months just
watch
this is like the dating version of who's
on first yeah
I think
who's on Casey who's you guys dating I'm
so curious like are you in relationships
no I didn't get your name what's your
name I'm Kyle Kyle yeah you're not a
relationship now are you in a
relationship yeah you are Kyla do you
live here now did you move down here for
me no I'm just here for a couple Casey
what's your favorite thing to do on a
Sunday night
yeah hopefully come back here again yeah
Church House of dragon
[Music]
probably start off with
[Music]
the evening it's more chill tell a long
story to someone that's not listening to
you
that's cool that sounds fun brunch and
shopping and having fun I have a puppy
Smiley so I hang out with her nice have
you ever gone on a date just because you
had a dog
now what kind of dog do you have I'm
curious
I adopted her
I need to do the
do the shepherd
oh it's like a medium-sized oh blue
healers are beautiful
do you know any Cowboys is that how you
met Brooke well Brooke had me dance with
a cowboy last night
interesting did you exchange digits
where did you slip your number this time
[Music]
[Laughter]
we haven't text at all you're a call
girl you like to call on the phone
that's all right that's uh
gotcha okay yeah he's a cowboy I don't
think he has a phone yet you're gonna
have to send him a smoke signal
waiting you would talk
yeah
I just didn't do it during date I don't
know there's a reason I'm alone I don't
know what to tell you anyway let's get
back onto you anyway uh this Cowboy from
last night is he uh tall was are you a
height guy like tall guys
interesting over six two no interesting
that's just a freakish at that point
okay I'm not
obviously they're attractive gotcha
gotcha gotcha yeah for sure Bob how tall
are you
five six really oh five nine yeah
I'm liking Bob more and more his
undersong himself he's just like I have
a three inch penis I think this is a hog
it's craziest
well thank you guys for going on a date
all at the same time uh you guys were
great hopefully you have sex with one of
these people
chances are good Bob J and Casey
everyone let him hear it oh all of them
[Applause]
well that was a show thank you for
coming on is there anything you'd like
to say uh any things you'd like to plug
or any dating advice uh
I have oh I'm here tomorrow night I have
a short film playing in the Austin After
Dark film festival so if you're around
tomorrow it's gonna be playing all day
starting at two
um and I don't know I got stand up on
YouTube if you want to check it out
follow me on Instagram at kylemara thank
you is that what you're here for the
little yeah Film Festival okay awesome
yeah give it up for Kyle give it up for
yourselves thank you so much good night
[Applause]